hola mi nombre es pablo como ya dijeron
y buenas tardes
un día
yo estaba en el liceo en clase de
derechos para ser exactos cuando de
pronto entraban dos profesoras más al
aula todos quedamos en silencio con esa
incógnita de que habremos hecho ahora
entonces una de ellas la más charlatán
ah por cierto perdón profe
comenzó
buenas tardes chiquilines nosotros
estamos realizando un proyecto llamado
'día foros por el cual queremos que
ustedes formen parte y se apropien de él
se llama día fueros por dos razones la
primera es que proviene del griego y
quiere decir diferentes
y la otra es que tenemos una referente
que es profesora de filosofía que no es
un dato menor
todos sin saber mucho acerca del
proyecto aceptamos aunque algunos para
decir la verdad no le gusta mucho la
idea
pero la verdad es que somos como ovejas
donde van unos cuantos
todos teníamos una incertidumbre
tremenda como de qué se tratará el
proyecto que tendremos que hacer y
principalmente nos servirá para nuestras
calificaciones
en la siguiente reunión nos explicaron
más o menos de qué se trataba el
proyecto y para que tengan una idea era
más o menos esto ya foros es un proyecto
del icio número 2 por el cual usted nos
avala monís por el cual tiene como
cometido fundamental estimular la
integración de los estudiantes y
comunidad en general
buscando demostrar que todos somos
diferentes pero iguales
al principio todos pensábamos que eso
estaba fuera de nuestro alcance como que
ese objetivo era utópico
una vez a la semana realizamos talleres
los mismos eran llevado a cabo por 40
integrantes que somos en diferentes
lugares en diversos lugares
ellos tenían en tienen el objetivo de
fomentar la convivencia y la empatía por
el otro entre los que concurren también
nos involucramos
diferentes actividades que realizan
nuestras alianzas la misma sociedad
entre
organizaciones sociales e instituciones
educativas
salimos de nuestro liceo para realizar
actividades comunitarias y hacer llegar
nuestra postura al máximo de personas
posibles para mí en especial es muy
importante hacer llegar nuestra postura
porque la gente puede tener otra
mentalidad haciendo que nuestra
comunidad sea más equitativa
pero todos sabemos que para realizar
dichos talleres actividades y demás
necesitamos fondos y para ello nosotros
realizamos beneficios al nombre de
nuestro proyecto
en especial el que más me marcó fue una
feria que realizamos en la plaza
que tiene el nombre de mercado de pulgas
yo en especial era
tesorero es por eso que no tenía mucha
interacción con las personas porque data
porque trataba de realizar mi labor lo
más rápido posible y profesionalmente no
de pronto en el medio de toda la gente
de la multitud vi a un señor que miraba
con mucha atención a todos los puestos y
por esa casualidad es por así decirlo
los llamé y le dije aquí tiene
diferentes folletos que por lo cual le
pueden servir él me hizo diferentes
preguntas por las cuales yo les contesté
y se fue
nosotros seguimos realizando nuestras
actividades y al cabo de una hora más o
menos el mismo regresó con un folleto
con un sobre en la mano y me llamó
diciéndome quiero que el nombre de
ustedes esté bien en alto nadie sabía
quién era en especial yo ni cuando queda
tenía ni a qué ni a qué se dedicaba
dicho proyecto de hecho folleto perdón
tenía un monto de dinero muy elevado en
dólares si como escucharon
una persona diferente a nosotros nos
donó de dinero
y esto me llevó a una frase
una acción vale más que mil palabras
principalmente me hizo reflexionar mucho
derrumbando la idea que tenía de que
nuestra de que nuestro objetivo era una
utopía
dentro de todos nuestros talleres se
encuentra el taller retractarse por el
cual propone reflexionar y concientizar
a todas las personas
sobre la cuestión quién soy si no puedo
ver escuchar sentir si me cuesta o si no
puedo aprender siempre y cuando
fomentando la actividad física sacando
las barreras
haciendo que nuestro taller se disfrute
al máximo
a medida que llevamos trabajando
aprendiendo y continuando con nuestro
objetivo llegamos a una estadística
sabían que 2 de cada 10 de ustedes son
los que ayudan a un no vidente a cruzar
la calle
es una estadística abrumadora de verdad
entonces que se entiende hoy en día por
inclusión equidad solidaridad
es un número
un discurso o tan solo una estadística
bueno les cuento que es para mí y para
foros inclusión es estar en la piel del
otro
derribar todas esas barreras que no lo
dejan participar ya saben a qué me
refiero verdad a todas aquellas barreras
físicas intelectuales prejuicios y demás
por esta razón y dejamos una forma de
trabajar con y para la comunidad
derribando todo tipo de barreras
saliendo del aula sacar todo tipo de
prejuicios establecidos por la sociedad
y principalmente caminando hacia el
cambio
de construir para construir
empezamos siendo 40 40 estudiantes de
bachillerato y hoy en día somos 70
porque se nos suman las nuevas
generaciones de compañeros y compañeras
que comienzan a trabajar ya formarse en
la activa participación ciudadana
en busca de equidad e igualdad de
oportunidades y tratando de sacar esa
brecha de desigualdad de género y
principalmente sacando la brecha de todo
tipo de discriminación
apostando a la utopía de la inclusión
siguiera siendo una acción
formar parte de un proyecto como este
hace que la gente tenga otra perspectiva
permitiéndote realizar acciones que
pueden ayudar mucho a tu entorno y a tu
comunidad para que sea más equitativa y
solidaria
y ahora me pregunto alguna vez salieron
en confort de su sillón o en frente de
la tele
para realizar una actividad comunitaria
o cuántas veces asombraron de la
discriminación social
bueno te invito a que seas parte del
cambio
no te quedes para que no te quedes
quieto y principalmente para que hagas
de tu entorno un ambiente más equitativo
para todos es por eso que les propongo
que nos sigan en las redes 10 foros
liceo 2 y con nuestro lema diferentes
pero iguales muchas gracias
[Aplausos]